[موسيقى]
الملايين من البشر اليوم يمكنهم ان
يتحولوا الى ابطال خارقين او حتى مخلوقات
سحريه والاهم يمكنك ان تصبح بطلا بمبلغ
زهيد لا يتجاوز ثمانيه دولارات سنويا
تطبيق الروسي اخترق اهتمامات العالم في
الايام الاولى من ديسمبر الجاري وما زالت
تفاعل معه كبيرا حسب صحيفه الوطن فان عدد
محمله وصل الى اربعه ملايين شخص في اقل من
خمسه ايام التطبيق يحمل اسم للانسان ويعمل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي لتعديل الصور الشخصيه
حيث يطلب من المستخدم تحميلا ما بين ثماني
الى عشر صور ومن ثم يحاور ملامح الشخص الى
صور مرتبطه بالخيال العلمي او الانمي بما
يتطابق معها بشكل كامل
الكثير من المؤثرين على المنصات الرقميه
بما في ذلك مشاهير هوليود استخدموه ورغم
الانبهار العالمي به للمتفاعلين مع
تحديثات صورهم الا انه يثير مخاوف جديه من
الوسط الفني الذي يطالب الناس بالتفكير
مرارا قبل دفع رسوم للتطبيق
الخبراء ايضا تناولوا الحديث عن الانسان
وقالوا انه استنساخ لحقوق العمل عبر سرقه
اعمال واساليب الفنانين
[موسيقى]
ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان الخبراء يرون ان
التطبيق ينتهيك حقوق النشر خصوصا وان
الواشنطن بوست تقول ان التطبيق يزيد من
مخاطر الاستغلال والتحرش كونه يسمح لاي
شخص بتحميل صور اناس اخرين هذا التطبيق
يعود بنا للذاكره لتطبيق انتشر قبل سنوات
قدمنا انفسنا من خلاله بالسلفي والان تظهر
نسخنا الكرتونيه
فهل تعتبر موجه بريئه او ترانس فقط او
ربما على العالم ان يتاهب للميتابرس
[موسيقى]